[Music]  i'm jesse waters and i've been at fox  for 18 years i wanted to work at fox  because i liked watching television  and i started in the basement of fox in  the newsroom i was working an intake so  i was labeling tapes i grew up on  television people come and see me on the  street and say jesse i remember you when  you were a little guy and running around  the streets who is the first president  people don't usually go from a producer  to on-air it's a unique journey someone  said no you have to go and do another  market and then come on air i said to  myself no i don't want to do it that way  and then one day i got a call jesse  you're now going to be on the five and i  had to take a breath and think my gosh  it's a lot of pressure you're only as  good as your last show every single day  there's pressure to be excellent and we  take that pressure very seriously